do you think there could be an
experiment
uh centered around consciousness i mean
you're plugged into the
neuroscience community i think for the
longest time the
quote-unquote c-word was totally not uh
was almost anti-scientific but now more
and more people are talking about
consciousness
elon is talking about consciousness uh
ai folks is talking about consciousness
it's it's still nobody knows anything
but it feels like
a legitimate domain of inquiry
that's hungry for a real experiment
so i have fortunately three short
answers to this
um uh the first one is later
i'm not i'm not particularly sustained i
i agree no
the joke i always tell is um there are
two things you never want to say to a
scientist
one is uh what do you do and the second
one is um
take as much time as you need and you
definitely don't want to say them in the
same sentence
um yeah i have three short answers to it
so there's a
um there's a cynical answer kind of
and it's not one i enjoy giving which is
that um
if you look into the 70s and 8 back at
the 1970s and 1980s
and even into the early 2000s there were
some very dynamic
very impressive speakers who are very
smart in the field of neuroscience and
related fields
who thought hard about the consciousness
problem and
fell in love with the problem but
overlooked the fact that the technology
wasn't there
so um i admire them for falling in love
with the problem but they gleaned
tremendous
taxpayer resources essentially for
nothing
and these people know who they are some
of them are alive some of them aren't
i'm not referring to francis crick who
was brilliant by the way and i thought
the klaustrom was involved in
consciousness which i think is a great
idea it's this
obscure structure that no one's really
studied people are now starting to study
it
so i think francis was brilliant and
wonderful but there it you know there
were
books written about it it makes for
great television
stuff and thought
around the table or after a couple
glasses of wine or whatever um
it's an important problem nonetheless
and so i think i do think the
consciousness
the issue is it's not operationally
defined right that psychologists are
much smarter than
um a lot of uh hard scientists in that
for the following reason they put
operational definitions they know that
psychology if we're talking about
motivation for instance they know they
need to put operational definitions on
that so that two laboratories can
know they're studying the same thing the
problem with consciousness is no one can
agree on what that is
and this was a problem for attention
when i was coming up so in the early
2000s people would argue what is the
tension is it spatial attention auditory
attention is it
and finally people are like you know
what we agree
have they agreed on that one i remember
sort of i remember
hearing people screaming a lot of
tension right they couldn't even agree
on attention so i was coming up as a
young graduate student i'm thinking like
i'm definitely not going to work on
attention and i'm definitely not going
to work on consciousness
and i wanted something that i could
solve or figure out i want to be able to
see the circuit
or the neurons i want to be able to hear
it on the audio i want to record from it
and then i want to do gain a function
and loss of function take it away
see something change put it back see
something change that systematic way and
that takes you down into the depths of
some stuff that's pretty
um uh plug and chug you know but
you know i'll borrow from something in
the the military because i'm fortunate
to do some work with
units from special operations and they
have beautiful language around things
because their world is not abstract
and they talk about three meter targets
10 meter targets 100 meter targets
and it's not an issue of picking the 100
meter target because it's more beautiful
or because it's more interesting if you
don't take down the three meter targets
and the 10 meter targets first
you're dead so that's a
i think scientists could pay to you know
adopt a more kind of military thinking
in that in that sense
the other thing that is really
important is that just because somebody
conceived of something and can talk
about it beautifully and can glean a lot
of
um resources for it doesn't mean that
it's led anywhere so
this isn't just true of the
consciousness issue and i don't want to
sound cynical but
i could pull up some names of molecules
that occupied
hundreds of articles in the very
premiere journals
that then were later discovered to be
totally moot for that
process and biotech companies fold it
everyone
and the lab pivots and starts doing
something different with that molecule
and
nobody talks about it because as long as
you're in the game
we have this thing called anonymous peer
review you can't afford to piss off
anybody
too much unless you have some other
funding stream and
i've avoided battles most of my career
but i pay attention to all of it
and i've watched this and i don't think
it's ego driven i think it's that people
fall in love with an idea i don't think
there's any there's not enough money in
science for people to sit back there
rubbing their hands together you know
the beauty of what neural link
and elon and and team because obviously
he's
very impressive but the the team as a
whole is really
what gives me great confidence in their
mission
is that he's already got enough money so
it can't be about that
he doesn't seem to need it at a level of
i don't know him but it doesn't he
doesn't seem to need it at a kind of an
ego level or something
i think it's driven by genuine curiosity
and the team that he's assembled
include people that are very kind of
abstract neuro
neocortex space-time coding people
they're people like matt who's a
neurosurgeon
you can't i mean you know you can't
bs neurosurgery failures and
neurosurgery are not tolerated so you
have to be very good
to exceptional to even get through the
gate and he's exceptional
and then they've got people like dan
adams who was at ucsf for a long time as
a good
good friend and known him for years um
who is very concrete studied the
vasculature in the eye and how it maps
to the vasculature and cortex when you
get a team like that together
you're going to have dissenters you're
going to have people that are high-level
thinkers people that are coders
when you get a team like that it no
longer looks like an academic
laboratory or even a field in science
and so i
think they're going to solve some really
hard problems
and again i'm not here they don't you
know
i have nothing at stake with them but
i think that's the solution you need a
bunch of people
who don't need first author papers who
don't need to complete their phd
who aren't relying on outside funding
who have a clear mission
and you have a bunch of people who are
basically will
adapt to solve the problem i like the
analogy of the three meter target
and the 100 meter target so the folks at
neural link are basically
many of them are some of the best people
in the world at the three meter target
like that you mentioned matt and your
surgery like they're solving real
problems there's no bs
philosophical uh smokes and weed and
look back and look at the stars
but
uh so both on elon and because i think
like this
i think it's really important to think
about the 100 meter
and the 100 meter is not even not even
100 meter but like
like the stuff behind the hill that's
that's that's too
too far away which is which is where i
put consciousness i'm
maybe i tend to believe
that uh consciousness can be engineered
i mean part of the reason
part of the the the business i want to
build
leverages that idea that consciousness
is a lot simpler that we've
than we've been talking about well if
someone can simplify the problem
right that would be wonderful i mean the
reason we can talk about something as
abstract as
face representations and fusiform face
area is because nancy kenwisher had the
brilliance
to tie it to the um kind of lower level
um statistics of visual scenes it wasn't
because she was like oh i bet it's there
that wouldn't have been interesting so
people like her
understand how to bridge that gap and
they put a
tractable definition so i just i
that's what i'm begging for in science
is tractable definition
this is what but i want people to sit
in the i want people who are really
uncomfortable with woo-woo
like consciousness like high-level stuff
to sit in that topic
and sit uncomfortably because it forces
them to then try to ground and simplify
it into something that's concrete
because too many people are just
uncomfortable to sit in the
consciousness room
because there's no definitions it's like
attention or
or intelligence in the artificial
intelligence community but the reality
is
it's easy to avoid that room altogether
which is what i mean
there's analogies to everything you've
said with the artificial intelligence
community
with the minsky and even alan turing
that talked about intelligence a lot
and then they drew a lot of funding and
then it crashed because they really
didn't do anything with it
and it was a lot of force of personality
and so on but that doesn't mean
the topic of the turing test and
intelligence
isn't something we should sit on and
think like
think like what is well first of all i
mean touring actually attempted this
with a touring test he tried to make
concrete
this very question of intelligence it
doesn't mean that we shouldn't
linger on it and uh
we shouldn't forget that ultimately that
is what our
efforts are all about in the artificial
intelligence community
and in the people whether it's
neuroscience
or whatever bigger umbrella you want to
use for understanding the mind
the goal is not just about understanding
layer two or three of the vision it's
it's to
understand consciousness and
intelligence and
maybe create it or just all the possible
biggest questions of our universe
that's that's ultimately the dream
absolutely and i think
what i really appreciate but appreciate
about what you're saying is that
everybody whether or not they're working
on a kind of low-level synapse that's
like a reflex and musculature or
something very
high-level abstract can benefit from
looking at those who prefer three you
know everyone's going after three meter
10 meter 100 meter targets in some sense
but to be able to tolerate the
discomfort of being in a conversation
where
there are real answers where the zeros
and ones are are
known zeros and ones and those the
equivalent of that in the nervous system
and also as you said for the people that
are very much like oh i can only trust
what i can see and touch
those people need to put themselves into
the discomfort of the high level
conversation because
what's missing is
conversation and conceptualization of
things
at multiple levels i think one of the
this is um
i don't gripe about my life's been
fortunate we've been funded from the
start and
we've been happy um in that in that
regard
and lucky and we're grateful for that
but i think one of the
challenges of research being so
expensive
is that there isn't a lot of time
especially nowadays for people to just
convene around a topic
because there's so much emphasis on
productivity
and so they're actually believe it or
not there aren't that many concepts
formal concepts in neuroscience right
now the last 10 years has been this
huge influx of tools and so people in
neural circuits and probing around and
connectomes it's been wonderful
but you know 10 20 years ago when the
consciousness
stuff was more prominent the c-word as
you said
what was good about that time is that
people would go to meetings and actually
discuss
ideas and models now it's sort of like
demons it's sort of like demonstration
day at the school science fair where
everyone's got their thing and
some stuff is cooler than others but um
i think we're gonna see a shift i'm
grateful that we have so many computer
scientists and theoreticians
and um or theorists i think they call
themselves
um somebody tell me what the difference
is someday
um and you know psychology
and even dare i say philosophy you know
these things are starting to converge we
you know neuroscience that the name
neuroscience there wasn't even such a
thing
when i started graduate school or as a
postdoc it was neurophysiology or you
were
anatomist or what now every it's sort of
everybody's invited and that's beautiful
that means that something's
useful is going to come of all this and
there's also tremendous work of course
happening
for the treatment of disease and we
shouldn't overlook that that's where you
know
endings you know eliminating reducing
suffering is also a huge initiative in
neuroscience so there's a lot of
beauty in the field but the
consciousness thing continues to be a
uh it's like an exotic bird
it's like no one really quite knows how
to handle it and it
dies very easily well yeah
i think also from the ai perspective
i so i view the brain as less sacred
uh i think from a neuroscience
perspective
you're a little bit more sensitive to bs
like
bs narratives about the brain or
whatever
i'm a little bit more uh comfortable
with just poetic bs about the brain as
long as it helps engineer intelligent
systems
well you know what i mean well and and i
have to you know i confess
um ignorance when it comes to you know
most things about coding and i'm i'm
have some quantitative ability but i
don't have strong quantitative leanings
and so
i i know my limitations too and so i i
think the next generation coming up you
know
a lot of the students at stanford are
really interested in quantitative models
and theory and ai
and i remember when i was coming up um
a lot of the people who were doing work
ahead of me i kind of rolled my eyes at
some of the stuff they were doing
um including some of their personalities
although i have great many great
senior colleagues so it's the way of the
world
so nobody knows what it's like to be uh
you know a young graduate student in
2020 except the young graduate students
so i
i know what i do i know there are a lot
of things i don't know
and um in addition to why i do a lot of
public education increase scientific
literacy and neuroscientific
thinking etc a big goal of mine is to
try and
at least pave the way so that these
really brilliant and forward-thinking
younger scientists can make the biggest
possible dent
and make what will eventually be all us
old guys and gals look stupid i mean
that's that's what we were all trying to
do
that's what we were trying to do so yeah
you